so hi everyone thank you for being here
today I'm gonna talk about how we built
a content-based recommender system for
financial news and before I begin a
quick shout out to my team at if day who
made all of this possible so some
background on us I don't know if you if
you read that news but had financial
dark blood is the biggest daily Dutch
newspaper that's focused on business and
financial news and about two years ago
we got this Google DNI grant on news
personalization so this is a digital
news initiative grant for innovation in
the media and one of the goals of this
grant was to for us to build a
personalized article article recommender
for our readers and one of the main
requirements of course since we are
talking about news data is that we have
to recommend articles that have been
recently published so we don't have
prior user interactions on them which
means we have a cold start problem so
and in this talk I'm going to talk to
you about how we build this recommender
how we tuned it in various experiments
and where it is right now so let's start
with the data that we have so like the
data that is really at the basis of this
system is the user interaction on our
website so we have the interaction
between users and articles and how do we
collect it so whenever user logs in to
our website we track keep track of the
articles that they have read but also
the articles that they didn't read so
for instance what you see here in the
bottom right of the of the article these
are links to articles that the user saw
on the website but never clicked on them
and this is what what we call implicit
feedback so we don't really know what is
the whether a user click on an article
whether they actually really liked the
article or whether it's something that
they are interested in but this is the
most easy data to collect and it's also
like the most realistic you can't always
expect your users to tell you whether
they liked or disliked something so this
positive and negative interactions of
the on the FD website this forms the
basis of our recommender
and this is what we use also as training
data so we collect all the clicks on
articles from the past and we use this
in the training process to create a
model we model this as a classification
problem actually so given a user and an
article pair we want to know how likely
it is that the user would click will
click on this article and we want to use
this to predict tomorrow's clicks right
so given a user an article see whether
or not they will read it and of course
since we are working with new articles
every day we have the call start problem
which means that we have to rely only on
the content of the articles and the user
profiles to make the recommendations you
cannot really rely on prior user
interactions like with methods such as
collaborative filtering which are very
standard for recommender systems so we
cannot use that so let me walk you a
little bit through through our training
process so of course we use a very
significant stack of Python libraries I
will try to point them to you at the
specific location where they are all
being used but this is like the
selection so like I said before we start
with the user interactions on our
website so we start with this positive
negative article clicks and right from
the start we notice that there is a
problem with this data so the data is
significantly imbalanced so a user is
much more likely to not read an article
on our website then they are to read it
so this can be a problem for for our
model because it could be overfitting on
negative feedback so we decided to
perform random sampling stab at the user
level and of course this can be replaced
with other methods such as popularity
based sampling which we have intend to
do some experiments around this but for
now the simplest reason was to just
sample out the negative examples that
are too many so that in the end we end
up with a balanced training data at the
user level so for each user we have a
balanced set of positive and negatives
this data then we can use to perform the
feature extraction which song will talk
more about okay
so I'm going to talk a bit about about
features we have show them so I've got
that let's first step back a bit to our
origins so here we have a user we have
an opcode we want to predict we simply
want to predict whether this you you
that would like this article but since
we have a severe coastal opening our new
soulmate we actually cannot simply use
the traditional a collaborative
filtering method so in order to in order
to make our prediction much more
meaningful we actually need to better
understand those our users and our
archives so we have to better understand
what are our users recently reading and
what are their potential interests and
we also need to enrich the articles to
better understand the article contest
article test itself and more importantly
we also need to try to find the
correlation between these two items like
whether this user is flowing the topic
of this article or whether the authors
of this article is among those favorites
so when we design our features we
actually have divided our features into
three parts the article features the you
the features and the you the article
features and we partially refer to our
these features into panels work so if
we're also interesting there are
assistants you can also check this
YouTube video by param so let's first
talk about our article features so the
article features mainly consists of two
parts the first metadata part is
directly provided by our journalist
such as content itself and what out all
sorts of the articles and even what is a
publication date of that articles and
the other part is about the enrichments
of the article the basic idea is that
besides these obvious meant data
actually we want to we'd like to know
more about this article itself
so we also want like we also want to
stress a fine ample how many paragraphs
of this disease and what is the
thoroughness of this article and even
what is a settlements course and what is
a word embeddings of this article
so we extract all these pyramids mainly
using open surah Tauba source toolkit
called test part which is a natural
language processing tool co-developed by
a few touch data scientists engineers
from FDA the past group at the arrow and
for us we are also part of that so if so
for the test pipe if merely use a spacey
and it can convert to your raw HTML
tracks into a clean and readable tags
and then extract the metadata from that
so if you're also interesting this
project you can also scan the QR code
for the link and for the wedding many
parts we actually use fast acts from the
Facebook which is pre-trade on the dutch
web dutch wikipedia pages so as you can
see for this article about the Rabobank
if we look as a final article
representations we can see it it has
like 39 number tendencies around 900
number of words and it also contains
tests like banking and for the you the
features so normally for the other
features people would like to use some
democratic features like age and gender
but at well every day we try to avoid
parse so we don't want to train a for
example the gender bias model or or due
to some privacy concerns we we decided
not to use demographic features but
instead we actually mainly focus on
their users previous reading behaviors
for example like the most the most read
tax and also soft of that user and and
also like what is average number of
words this users normal reason so
this is our lead lead data scientist
david and because since he is such a
power user of FD we always use his
profile as our experimental subject so
from his user profile presentations we
can see david read a lot of articles
about tech and media and technologies
and unfortunately he's also see that his
favorite also is from after editor so
the last part of the features is about
the user article correlation so for this
part we actually first look at the
overlap so for them for well whether the
text and/or the authors of this article
is among the users top 10 most Arab and
we also want to secondly we also want to
compare the current compare I mean
explicitly compare the user and article
features for them for whether the for
number whether the article ends of this
article is longer than the normal user
reading path columns and whether the
number of sentences of this actor is
exceeds the average number of centers of
this user normally reading so so finally
we can buy all these three kinds of
features into one big feature vector
which actually translates like 14k
colors well just most of them are just
cargo features like tags and authors so
that's it for the future part thank you
so we have this massive feature vector
right this 14,000 element feature vector
and well of course we decided to
calculate it all in the beginning so
that maybe we can reduce it later if we
see that some of the features are not
necessary but for now we keep everything
and then we can use this to train our
model
but before we can do that of course we
have to decide what model are we
actually training also maybe what data
and what what of these big features are
we actually going to keep so in order to
make these these decisions we did a
small experiment and we use this paper
from zalando as as a basis for our
experimental design and the set up was
of course it was offline so we had to
work on data that was already generated
on the website on the front page so we
collected all the interactions in the
month of January and we used the first
27 days for for training and the other
for validation and testing and for
evaluation metrics we used to ranking
based metrics so and ECG and mean
average precision mean average precision
actually combines ranking and
classification and we calculated on the
user level and the daily level using the
pi track eval python package which is
also like a nice small open-source
contribution so what model can be used
for this problem so we were in our
choice we were inspired by this paper
from face book on predicting clicks on
ads which of course it's not exactly the
same thing as news recommendations but
well similarly not in the sense that
they also have to deal with a large
volume of data and they propose this
ensemble model which combines a gradient
boosted decision tree that performs a
sort of a feature
reduction with a logistic regression
final layer to perform the
classification step so this is a bit of
a complicated model so we also decided
to test it in comparison with a simpler
gradient boosted decision tree model
that is used only for classification and
we also experimented with different
training methods so we saw we have these
three conditions fit where we need to
train a new model every day partial fit
where we retrain the previous day's
model using today's data but without
adding any new trees and partial fit
grow which is the same oz but with
adding new trees
so what is DVD team in case you are not
very familiar with this model so it's a
machine learning model that construct an
ensemble of weak decision tree learners
through gradient boosting so it has
decision trees at its basis and the way
it works is that at each iteration it
takes a sub sample of the training data
at random and without replacement and it
uses it to fit the model on and at the
end the model captures interactions
amongst the various predictors that are
generated in this way and why is this a
good model so the the main reason
actually has to do with our data so G by
DT is very good at dealing with
heterogeneous data so it can work very
well with a mix of continuous discrete
categorical features which is what we
you saw we have also feature
normalization is not required and
feature selection is inherently
performed during the learning process
which is pretty neat and of course it's
a nonlinear model so it can capture
nonlinear and non-additive relations
alright so let me jump to our results so
we first started by by looking at the
experiment on the simple GB DT model
that is trained in with the various
training setups so these graphs are a
little bit hard to read so I'll try to
explain them to you on the x-axis you
see the day of the month this is day of
the month of January on the y-axis you
have the evaluation matrix and then you
see in the blue graph we have the
partial fit the green is a partial fit
grow and the yellow is the fit
classifier and a point in this graph for
the fit model means that the model was
trained on data from that day so this is
the point for January 15 it means the
model was trained on January 15 data and
evaluated on our evaluation set for the
partial feed grow model and for for the
fit model for the partial fit models
it's a little bit different so here we
actually consider data from the previous
seven days including today so from
January 8
to January 15 and I will explain a bit
later why why this works better so yeah
same for the partial feed model and of
course for the evaluation we are more
interested in performance I towards the
the later end of the graph so for the
later days because that is a bit closer
to the evaluation set but we also want
to see kind of a stable performance over
time and we don't want to see all that
big variation in the model so given
these conditions we found that actually
the partial feed grow model so where we
are continuously adding new trees it
works the best this is the green the
green one the fit model has a little bit
uneven performance so you see this very
big fluctuation in the orange orange
line and the partial fit model is kind
of the worst of both worlds so it also
has a little bit lower performance and
it fluctuates a lot and you might have
noticed that we are being a bit unfair
to the fit model so we are only using
one day's worth of training data whereas
for the other ones we are using seven
days and we did actually experiment with
using multiple days for the fit model
the problem is that using this training
this model is very expensive so you have
to store all of this data into memory in
order for the model to be able to do
this random selection from the data at
training time which is very expensive we
did see that using two and three days in
the past actually improves the
performance for the fit model but it did
not improve it by that much that it
would really justify these costs in
terms of memory so yeah we stuck with
the partial feed grove for now we also
experimented with the Facebook ensemble
model right so you remember this
combined GB DT logistic regression model
and we did a lot of experiments kind of
combining different ways of training and
in the end what we saw is that it
doesn't really do better than the simple
gradient boosted tree model so what you
see in the purple line that was the
model that I showed you previously so
that still does better and so why why
didn't this model perform well so we
believe it because the the logistic
regression they
is actually quite difficult to tune and
that's because the output of the GB DT
model that does the feature reduction
it's not really interpretable so of
course we try to reuse the the parameter
the hyper parameters and the setup that
the Facebook paper used but but because
the problem is not exactly the same that
evening didn't work in the same way so
in the end actually having the simpler
and more interpretable model paid off
for us
we also did some experiments in how much
data should we use it should be trained
on so specifically we were interested in
how many days in the past should we
consider for our model and what we saw
is that more data is not necessarily
always better and that's because recency
is a very important feature in our data
so the recency of news is very important
when predicting what what users will
read tomorrow what we also saw was that
the relation between the number of days
and the performance is not linear so
actually the best performance we saw for
when training on the previous three and
seven days so that was also interesting
another interesting finding about the
data we found that actually we can
remove up to 50 percent of the
interactions on the website that we use
in training and not experience a loss in
the in the performance and that's
because people kind of read the same the
same articles there it is popularity
bias in our data and this is also an
issue with training on offline data
right is that people get exposed to the
same static front page they only read
the same articles and before I go on I
should also mention here that just
because we are removing data doesn't
mean we don't have historical data in
the in the training so actually the user
features if you remember those contain
the the user profiles that have been
collected over the previous I believe
three or four months so just because we
are removing interactions doesn't mean
we don't have long-term historical data
in our features so that's why this works
so well so I think we're a bit tired of
this wobbly graph so I'm just gonna
verbally summarize the feature oblation
experiment so you remember we had this
massive feature set 14,000 feet features
with a lot of sparsity of course from
all of those categories
and we did an extensive feature ablation
experiment where we worked with
different feature categories individual
features as well and what we saw in the
end was that unfortunately we do need
all of these features so it's a little
bit disappointing for us but yeah what
can I do
and the the reason we think is because
even though we did see some non
performing features on the individual
level whenever we did a batch removal of
all of our like low performing features
it would take out big chunks of the
decision tree actually so in the end
yeah it didn't make sense to do that
that doesn't mean that all features are
equally important though so we did see
that the the most important features or
predictions were the user article
features so maybe this is a bit
intuitive or not surprising but the most
important ones are the overlap in
authors and overlapping tags between the
user profile and the article so just to
conclude all of this experimental work
so we found that the simpler dv/dt model
is better and it's always easier to
understand we also found that using less
data in terms of days and user
interactions does not mean worse
performance and finally we saw that the
combined user article features are the
most important but that actually all
features contribute a little bit also a
practical tip from our implementation
which we found out the hard way so XD
boost does not support multi-threading
yeah so okay now that we decided on the
model we have this gradient boosted
decision tree with partial fit grow that
we trained on seven days we can use it
to to get our trained model that we
generate every day so some knowledge
about implementation the sampler and the
feature extraction they work as REST API
is that we implemented using flask and
the training is actually done once a day
in a virtual machine that gets destroyed
when the training is is over
alright so after training of course you
can also do prediction and here we start
from user article pairs that that we
don't have labels on and this can also
be
this can also be negative labels so
articles that the user saw yesterday but
did not click on so we can still predict
on that and we perform feature
extraction using the method I showed you
earlier using the trained model we can
generate a prediction which is in a we
get basically a confidence probability
for both the positive and the negative
label and this we can use to generate a
ranked list of articles for the user so
that we know for each user these are the
most likely articles that they will
enjoy in that day and these components
the feature extraction was the same like
the training feature extraction actually
so it's stored in flask and the
prediction is also stored in flask so
this is how it looks like on the FD
website we have we presented in two
parts on the website so we for we first
have a section what you see on the left
side with the articles that the user
missed in the last seven days and we
have a small widget where the user can
see the articles from the last 24 hours
ranked in terms of confidence and some
notes about how this is served so for
the training we do to retrain a new
model every day and we I didn't show you
this but we did experiment with training
frequency as well and this seemed like
it was the best best setup so at 11:00
p.m. we kind of collect all the data
that we had all the interactions we
train the model and then we store it in
s3 bucket so we use Amazon Web web
services for our infrastructure and for
the predict we first do a batch predict
every morning for all the users and all
the articles that have been published in
that day and then one hour after the
last visit we refresh their their
predictions so we don't offer live live
predictions we have this cage the
recommendation scores that we put you
know dynamodb so because it's too
expensive to generate it whenever the
user is visiting the website and if you
want to know more about the
infrastructure this is like very big
topic in and of itself so our data
engineer gave a talk at closure days
actually
later li er this year which I left you
the link here alright so where is this
project now so actually we are finally
doing a online testing for for this
recommendation system when we are
currently collecting data from real
users and we hope by the end of next
week to have our first results and we
are also interesting in measuring things
like usefulness so what I didn't mention
yet but it's very important to us so
clicks are really not the only way to
present information and to evaluate
recommender systems so our general is
they are also very concerned about
things like diversity of recommendations
serendipity dynamic nosov the news and
we we are currently investigating this
and we want to see how also how our
readers respond to these aspects and the
funk will show you some preliminary
results on this on this work thank you
so so as John said we we just don't want
to rely or our evaluations only on the
documentation accuracy so actually we
also have done some preliminary
evaluation on some you usefulness
metrics like coverage and integrity so
for coverage we actually mainly compare
the front page highlight did articles
and with our top five recommendations
the front page highlight articles are
manually selected by our editors and
they are shown on the front page and
they and everybody got the same five
articles each time so and for the
coverage part we actually found that if
we compare our recommendations with
front page highlight articles as
individual user level we actually found
that users get less coverage in our
recommendations which means that
actually our recommendations are more
personalized okay I think I may need to
explain a bit about
the cover so for the coverage we
actually are mainly measures how much
percentage of the daily publications
which is exposed to the to the for the
others right okay so but Wow
so as a individual user level we
actually found our recommendations are
more personalized but well if we look at
the coverage over the whole how you
decide we actually found that our
recommendations actually expose much
broader articles to our users and we
believe that that could actually help us
to tackle the non tell a reading problem
on our web and we also measure the
diversity scores for those two lists in
terms of attributes like section tags
and authors we actually and we actually
found that our top five recommendations
are more diverse instructional and
content and highlight articles are more
diverse on authors which is actually
also partially makes sense because we
also found that authors and tags are
quite two important features in our
models who make recommendations which
would lead our recommendations much more
similar officers that's a primary in
valuation results thank you so I think
we've actually reached the end of the
talk a little bit early so we have more
time for questions I just want to
reiterate the the lessons that we
learned from this experimental process
so as I mentioned previously do consider
using a simpler model it's sometimes it
really works better and it's always
easier to understand what is happening
also consider using less data of course
it's it's much cheaper to implement and
it does not necessarily mean worse
performance as we have seen and finally
yes combined user article features were
the most meaningful that we found but
actually all features can contribute a
little bit especially with the models
that are based on decision trees that do
the feature selections themselves it's
worth maybe exploring a larger feature
set I also have compiled here the list
of all of the references the time
during during this talk if you wanna
take a photo of it or yeah keep it for
further reference thank you very much
I'm looking forward to your questions
[Applause]